hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
panel presentation multiplex rt pcr to
accurately detect and differentiate
respiratory viruses presenting similar
clinical symptoms
this webinar is a part of 2021 clinical
diagnostics and research
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
thermo fisher scientific for more
information about thermo fisher
scientific go to
thermofisher.com
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
first participate by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation
you can find the live chat located at
the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
any questions you have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'll now present today's speakers
lauren miller scientist clinical
applications marketing support thermo
fisher scientific and anami patel ph.d
chief science officer poplar healthcare
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
lauren you may now begin your
presentation
this winter the united states healthcare
system faces a special challenge
a potentially severe influenza season is
expected to coincide with continued
circulation of cyrus kobe 2.
in this scenario it's critical to have a
single multi-target assay which can
detect and differentiate between these
viruses
the tacpaf covid19 flu a fluvi combo kit
is an ideal solution for researchers and
healthcare providers
so i'd like to start with two key
concepts number one the similarities and
differences between sars cov2 and
influenza
and then secondly i'd like to talk about
the implications of co-circulation of
these two viruses this flu season
so number one when we're comparing and
contrasting the two viruses
the cobin 19 pandemic is an infectious
disease caused by a novel coronavirus
that emerged in late 2019
and the graph that you're seeing here is
data from the world health organization
of covid 19 cases around the world from
january 1st to today
and you can see the different regions
are depicted with different colors
so you can see that coven 19 infection
increases and decreases in particular
locations due to factors such as
emerging variants vaccine distribution
and infection prevention policy so
shutdowns quarantine business closures
and until herd immunity is achieved we
really don't know what the
epidemiological pattern of copen-19
spread will be
whether it'll follow the seasonal
pattern seen in other respiratory
viruses or not
the seasonal flu on the other hand has
been around for a while so we know that
the seasonal flu circulates in these
cyclical peaks which coincide with the
seasons
the flu season in the northern
hemisphere is from october to may
peaking from december to february
and depending on the year anywhere
between 3 and 11 of the us population is
thought to suffer from a symptomatic flu
infection every year
so when we compare these illnesses
hospitalizations and deaths and numbers
between the two viruses it's really
important to remember that the kobit 19
situation is so new and it's changing so
much
that experts are still trying to
estimate the mortality rate of cobit 19.
so the current thinking is that it
thought to be substantially higher
possibly 10 times or more than most
strains is a flu
so when we talk about influenza it's
important to realize that we're talking
about four strains or four types of
influenza
there's a b
c and d
influenza type c
generally only causes mild illness while
influenza type d viruses are not known
to infect humans so really we focus on
influenza a and influenza b it are these
viruses that cause seasonal epidemics of
disease every winter in the u.s
influenza a
is further divided into subtypes
while influenza type b
we don't talk about subtypes so much as
distinct lineages
for example victoria and yamagata
what is the significance between
differentiating between
flu a and floopy after all the patient
treatment is very similar whether you
have flu a and flu b
both a and b have potential for mild to
severe disease
we differentiate between the two because
influenza poses an ongoing risk to
global human public health and testing
helps us monitor the subtypes and
strains that circulate each year
this is very powerful and very important
for informing vaccine design
assessing antigenic drift and shift and
assessing the impact on different
population groups
so taking a look at the viruses
themselves both sars cozy ii as well as
influenza are enveloped single-strand
rna viruses distinguished by the
glycoprotein spike embedded in the
envelope so here on the left we can see
basar's kobe 2 with its infamous spike
protein depicted here in purple
and influenza here on the right and
instead of one spike protein there are
two glycoproteins that are kind of the
definitive characteristics there's
neuraminidase and hemoglobin
it's these two proteins on the surface
that influence the virus that contain
the major antigens targeted by
antibodies
with both viruses being a single strand
rna virus both of these viruses mutate
and
when we talk about stars cov2 we talk
mostly about novel viral variants
so most of these mutations affect the s
gene and emerging variants are
classified based on the risk for public
health so we're all familiar with the
alpha beta delta and gamma strains so
these variants have garnered widespread
attention because the rapid emergence in
populations and evidence of transmission
and or clinical applications
when we talk about influenza viruses the
mutation rate and the mutation
mechanisms are similar
but we talk more in terms of antigenic
drift and shift again because this virus
has been around longer and we're able to
track the strains much better
influenza's high mutation rate means
that acquired immunity no longer offers
enduring protection against the whole
class of influenza viruses
so new subtypes can be more virulent and
potentially lead to higher mortality
rates than their predecessors
both the seasonal flu and copen19
are transmitted easily through contact
droplets and aerosol
whereas covid19 is more contagious and
there are more super spread ribbons
they have similar symptom onset and
incubation periods although cova-19 is
really characterized by this longer
incubation time symptom onset can be
anywhere between 2 and 14 days after
infection
similarly for
the incubation time when you're
contagious the seasonal flu is slightly
shorter than coping 19.
and in both cases asymptomatic patients
can be asymptomatic or have mild
moderate or severe diseases in both
cases
so in terms of symptoms covenanting and
influenza are extremely similar
it's very difficult for healthcare
providers to differentiate between these
two viruses based on symptoms alone
both of them can produce fever chills
cough sore throat runny nose headache
fatigue
and in both cases they can lead to
severe disease such as pneumonia acute
respiratory distress syndrome
myocarditis multiple organ failure etc
and it's important to know that even
though these two diseases have very
distractingly similar symptoms most of
the time
it is extremely important that
healthcare providers diagnose influenza
or starch copy2 infection by
confirmation
testing for an example there are some
severe or certain symptoms
or treatments that are very different
between the two diseases
so a cytokine storm is one potential
symptom of a covid19
case and this is where excessive
production of pro-inflammatory cytokines
can lead to acute respiratory distress
syndrome aggravation causing widespread
tissue damage multi-organ failure and
even death
so the drugs used to treat cytokine
storms are immunosuppressants which of
course are contraindicated for seasonal
flu because it reduces the patient's
ability to fight the virus
therefore despite the similarities of
symptoms when it comes to certain severe
symptoms or complications
diagnosis and confirmation testing is
critical
so now that we've talked
quite a bit about the similarities and
differences between these two viruses i
like to discuss the implications of
co-circulation of these two viruses this
year
the patients with acute respiratory
illness symptoms
can either kind of go one of two ways
they can require hospitalization
such as your old high risk or a nursing
home resident
or you can have mild symptoms not
requiring hospitalization
if you do require hospitalization the
cdc recommends
that the healthcare provider orders a
multiplex nucleic acid detection assay
for influenza aab and stars kobe 2.
so in this situation we can see that the
tacpas covid19 flu ace bluebee combo kit
is an ideal solution for researchers and
healthcare providers
and even for those not requiring
hospitalization the cdc still recommends
testing for stars kobe 2
as well as testing for influenza if the
results affect clinical management or
for infection control
it's important to note here that stars
kobe 2 and influenza virus co-infection
can occur
in looking at the slide overall it's
easy to imagine the increased burden
that this could have on the united
states healthcare system
with a higher number of severe influenza
illnesses the hospitalizations and
intensive care unit admissions would all
compete with 16 codes in 19 cases
so if you think of you know doctor or
nurse burnout it's the same doctors and
nurses who would treat either patient
and even for those not requiring
hospitalization we would see an
increased demand for testing
you know it used to be that if you had
mild symptoms for a seasonal flu in the
winter you would just go home against
the veterans but now
we need to get tested for cobin 19. it's
extremely difficult to tell the
difference of is this a cold a flu or
the onset of coven 19.
looking at the treatment so
with co-infection of these viruses or
co-circulation of these viruses excuse
me it's important to understand that
even though the symptoms as well as mild
managed management may be similar
treatment options for severe or high
risk cases are very different so in
addition to the cytokine
immunosuppressant example that we saw
before
overall we can see that treatment for
severe cases
are extremely different whether it's
coping 19 or flu so copin 19 there are
monoclonal antibodies that can be
effective as long as they're initiated
early on in the course of infection and
for the flu we have antivirals such as
tamiflu which can be extremely effective
when given within the first two days
following influenza symptom presentation
what i want to point out here is that
even though these treatments are
independent of viral variant or subtype
of course they're very different between
each other so you can't use influenza
antivirals to combat a covenant
infection and vice versa
with these two co-circulating viruses
it's also important to mention
the importance of vaccination
so both of these viruses are pretty
effectively inhibited by public health
safety measures you know hand washing
covering your mouth covering your
sneezes wiping down surfaces avoiding
contact social distancing
but it's really the vaccination that
provides the protective important
protection from cobia 19 and influenza
globe 19 vaccines
are now available there are a few
different authorized for use under eua
it's recommended for everyone at least
12 years or older and the cdc is now
recommending that certain people be
eligible for proven 19 booster shops
flu vaccine on the other hand is updated
every year based on the surveillance
data of influenza viruses detected in
the previous season
there are several vaccines that are fda
licensed
and they're recommended particularly for
high-risk groups
the thing that i want to focus on
is really the updating annually based on
last slus data
and the reason that that's important is
because we virtually had no influenza
season last year
if we take a look at this data this is
the circulation of flu a and b in the
united states
and we can see this cyclical pattern
every year rising and falling where we
would expect to see
influenza season
until last year word virtually drops off
into nothing so this red rectangle here
on the right indicates the beginning of
the 19 cobin 19 pandemic
this is also the beginning of social
distancing um stay-at-home orders school
venue and business closures bans on
public gatherings travel restrictions
contact tracing and quarantine
so we can really see that the
effectiveness of all of these measures
against covid19
is also extremely effective against
other respiratory illnesses such as
influenza
and
even though it looks like there's just a
flat line for the influenza
last year if we zoom in
we can see that there was in fact a flu
season
it was just very small on a much much
smaller scale than normal
so i want you to take two things away
from this number one
we have extremely limited amount of data
from last year's influenza strains to
inform this year's vaccine designs
and number two this record low activity
means a lower population immunity which
puts us all at risk for increased
disease this year
so this is a graph kind of showing the
easing of public
measures during the coven 19 pandemic so
this graph on the left
december 10th of last year before the
vaccine became available in this dark
red coloring you can see that most
countries around the world have very
stringent protective measures
since then you can see these lightening
of colors so kind of this global easing
of protection measures slowly but surely
as the world starts to open up
so this easing of social distancing
measures is what experts believe might
lead to a surge of influence and
infections
so just to recap our
concerns for the 2021-2020 flu season
are these
higher activity of influenza virus is
anticipated
easing social distancing and other
measures may lead to surge in infections
decreased population immunity due to
non-pharmaceutical intervention and
lower exposure to influence in the
previous season
and limited data available for influenza
strains in the previous season for
vaccine design which increases the
likelihood of influenza vaccine mismatch
so overall testing recommendations
from expert groups around the world such
as the european center for disease
prevention and control as well as the
academy and medical sciences
is basically in strong support of
multiplex testing for both stars kobe 2
and influenza during this flu season
running multiple tests on each patient
is difficult and it's expensive
combining targets for these viruses into
a single test makes distinguishing
between these infections much easier and
can help physicians choose the
appropriate treatments and protocols for
their patients
this being said the takpath covid19 flu
a-fubi combo kit is an ideal solution
for healthcare providers and researchers
and with that i'd like to introduce dr
anami patel for clinical performance of
the tacpac coven 19 flu a fluvi combo
kit as compared to other multiplex rt
pcr tests
thank you lauren so much for nice
introduction uh so um
uh i work here at popular healthcare
which is part of path here i located uh
in memphis tennessee uh popular
healthcare is a centralized laboratory
for histology and core
diagnostic work providing services to
all 50 states
within u.s
we do offer comprehensive molecular
diagnostic testing along with other
pathology services to our clients
including primary care physicians and
private practices throughout the country
here
as we know when we were hit by
pandemic uh in spring of 2020 uh popular
healthcare and our group immediately
started looking into
offering this kovit testing
and we were
very fortunate to develop our own as a
cdc based
and apply for
city
fda
emergency authorization use
so
so we once we validated and uh applied
for ua that was around uh early april
2020
and uh uh
then immediately we started building our
capacity by looking into different
platforms
uh pcr uh and reagents and supply as as
every every other lab
went through that
so
so currently we offer uh sarsko with two
diagnostic tests
by using different platforms uh and
reagents such as thermofisher stack path
kovid assay
rosh kobas assay and applied biocode
and
another one hologic panther assay so
that way we have a good capacity
and
good service
around sarsko we do
in addition to performing uh laboratory
testing we also have here at popular
healthcare our own collection site drive
through where we can help our community
with people who come register
and we collect the test and
offer the testing at the same place and
lastly
we have been doing surveillance testing
uh since beginning of this year by whole
genome sequencing uh illumina sequencing
uh platform
so
this is a very comprehensive source cov2
uh capacity and uh
testing we have developed over the last
uh 18 months or so
so
so where we are now what what we are up
to uh we are obviously getting ready for
upcoming flu season as lauren mentioned
uh last year we did not see any
influenza activity uh very evident from
her graph uh and the several reasons
behind as well
so
several months ago
here in our lab we started looking and
preparing for upcoming influenza season
and why why we were interested uh what
what what was the reasoning behind that
since we have been doing comprehensive
respiratory pathogen panel testing for
several years now and during uh pandemic
upcoming influencer season
there was a need uh our
clients hospital plants uh urgent care
nursing homes they started asking us and
and and the reason be also the symptoms
which lauren explained very well
that
it's hard to differentiate somebody who
has a respiratory infection or symptoms
whether it is uh sars cov2 or influenza
a or b
so there was a need to look into
and at the same time
cdc last year around september august
september month uh
they put in their clinical guideline uh
the strong recommendation around testing
for uh influenza as well as
sarsko we do
and they were able to get fda emergency
authorization use for their first test
and
as we know uh
in 2020 we didn't see any uh influenza
and uh because of the good measures and
other things which was uh discussed
earlier so given this uncertainty our
lab decided to look into uh multiplex
test where where we can
use the same uh keep the same capacity
and perform the test
and give the results as a combo either
influenza
or kovid rather than two different tests
is there some multiplex testing
we could do
so
as part of that
the single test
can use up the capacity as i just said
so the combo test can allow lab like us
to process more tests in a given time
period using the same amount of reagent
and then at the same time
it can help control the spread of uh not
just rsco we do but influenza virus as
well
and uh helps uh uh
uh ongoing uh surveillance support uh
for for sars kovi as well and
uh importantly very importantly for us
uh the testing material what what we are
using and sometimes here and there we
still see some shortage of the supply
especially around
consumables
so
so we
we looked into what we have uh and combo
test uh how we can adapt uh so we looked
into our within our lab what uh capacity
platforms was uh and training expertise
staffing
uh and
so uh three things came to our mind
three platforms thermo fisher uh uh rosh
6800 which we have in our lab and
applied biocode mdx 3000 three different
systems and these three
uh platform already available combo test
as fta eua
so
uh first uh just showing you the
workflow around uh thermo fisher's uh uh
tech pack kovit 19 influenza a and
influenza b combo test uh performed on
7500 plus dx
so once we receive the sample
in vtm or saline
then we prep the sample what that means
is we extract the nucleic acid as part
of the workflow and once the nucleic
acid is extracted on kingfisher
instrument
which can do
up to 94 patient samples on a given run
plus
two
external controls
so once 96 samples are being extracted
it can go on 7500 fast dx instrument
where
we can run either 384 samples or
94 samples plus two controls
and there it requires uh the extraction
part the the prep sample part requires
around 30 minutes and then
once we set up a pcr and put it on that
7500 dx instrument which would take
around hour and four minutes and then
it has a software built in onto the
instruments
where we can analyze review the result
and this entire workflow in our lab for
sarsko kovi 2 as well as a
combo test
it is bi-directionally interfaced so
order can come through our lymph system
into the instrument we can process a
sample review the result and release the
result in our own lis system
so uh
and the other two workflows uh which i
mentioned uh the instruments we already
have in our lab uh coba 6800 uh we
evaluated uh or as part of this study
we ran the samples on the uh 6800 system
with with cobas reagents uh for
influenza a b and uh sarsko v2
and
in that workflow it requires sample
would come into the lab we would
transfer
uh 600 microliter of the sample into
another tube
uh in the hood and that will go on 6800
analyzer that's where and along with the
sample we load we would load uh reagents
for for this assay as well as the
consumables required consumables
and it will process the sample so the
extraction
uh pcr uh amplification and detection
would happen on on that run again we can
run 94 samples and two controls uh on a
given batch
and then next set of samples can go on
after 30 minutes or so on 6800 system
on the third system applied bio code
where
we would we would need to extract the
samples on a kingfisher instrument uh
which is uh from thermo fissure and then
once samples are being extracted in this
case rna then we would set up a pcr and
it will go on applied biocode mdx 3000
system
and uh
amplification and detection again fda
eua
sa
so both of this workflow uh again
requires around three and a half hours
so time wise uh
uh it is about the same uh process
on this slide i just uh put all three
platforms uh uh side by side
and for a clinical evaluation of uh
tag path kovid flow a and flu b test
which we were very interested in uh and
compare with kobas 6800 and applied
biocode in our lab
we were able to
retrieve uh previously
tested positive and negative sample so
here in this study we were able to get
60 uh sars kobe 2 19 uh
i mean sarsko with two samples positive
uh and these samples were from september
of 2021 uh and i emphasized that
because this
positive samples we were able to as part
of our ongoing surveillance process uh
we were
we we had access to the data result uh
on the variance and most of most of
these samples which were included in
this study
were
delta variants
so and then
we we were able to get 60 influenza a
positive uh samples from 209
2019 influenza season
and that time as a clinical standard of
care test uh we were running on power of
our instrument
so those 60 influencer positive
result from biofar rpp
uh panel we we we were able to run uh on
combo test by all three methods and then
limited number of influenza b uh
46 positive samples
and then
uh another set of 60 negative samples
for
all three pathogens
we included in this study
let's look at the data
how
it performed
so before that uh i was i'm just trying
to show you here
whenever we do
this kind of clinical evaluation with
different reagent and workflow we want
to be inclusive of with our samples
not just a certain number of positive
but how diverse they are in terms of
viral load and in this situation viral
load would be uh based on the ct value
so and this city value is once we ran
the sample
what city value we had
between each platform for combo test
so here in this case uh on the
upper left top uh
graph where it shows us influencer a ct
value and dark color
uh is a thermo combo test
and light blue color is rosh cobas
so
they are pretty uh
good representation between
different city value or viral load or
severity of infection
a similar way for influenza b those 46
cases
and for covet 19
another set of 60 samples
we were not able to uh put this
information for applied biocode
and the reason being uh that platform uh
gives us mfi value
rather than ct value which doesn't
correlate with uh
either viral load or severity of
infection so i'm just showing here the
comparison between uh thermo fissure and
rose cobas system
so let's look at uh how it performed uh
and uh first uh 60 set of data
uh influencer a
uh and and we evaluated in terms of
positive predictive value and negative
predictive value so positive predictive
value it
gives us an idea around how sensitive
clinically so a patient had infection
and we tested with any diagnostic assay
uh what was it able to uh test positive
or not
and that would depend on um
the limit of detection or analytical
sensitivity we have not done any
analytical validation or analytical
performance between these three reagents
because it is very well
documented in each of their package
insert
we were mostly interested in how it
performs clinically with clinical
samples in our lab
so uh for influenza a
uh when we ran
uh and and then upper left uh
graph shows comparison between tag path
uh
covid influenza a and b compocate versus
cova's combo gate so
60 positive samples gave us results by
both method positive
and all together 170
samples we ran for uh which were
negative by influencer for influenza a
so all that matched now remember
we only ran
60 negative samples for all three
targets but here 170 numbers include
influence of b
negative uh oh sorry influencer b
positive result would consider
as influencer a negative
so that way number is higher for
negative predictive value
so in this case uh the positive and
negative predictive value uh compared
between uh taxpayer covet combo test and
cobas uh sars kobe combo test is hundred
percent uh
similar way
between applied biocode and cobas uh
other two methods uh similar result
hundred percent
and when we compare tag path versus
applied bio code uh
uh again positive predictive value and
negative predictive value
were a hundred percent
when we ran uh total 46 positive samples
uh for influenza b
um uh on
on tech path uh covet combo assay we
were
able to get all 46 implants a beep for
pulse positive as well as on coba's
combo test
similarly
when we ran on applied biocode
with applied barcode reagents uh
all 46
were positive
on their platform and koba's 100 percent
and
comparison between uh
taxpayers covered and applied by our
code was 100 as well
for positive and negative that gives us
the clinical sensitivity and uh
specificity at 100
so um
now uh when we looked at the results for
60 positive uh in this here we had uh 61
positive for uh
sars kovi 2 and all 61 uh
match between tagpathkovit and kobas as
well as applied biocode and cobas and uh
uh
techpath covid and
applied bio code kovic
so
remember uh these are different data i'm
presenting uh but by running one sample
uh since it is being all three ss being
combo test uh we
uh get all three results same time
except on applied biocode uh their
test method is first you run influenza
for influenza a and b
and uh from the extraction extracted
nucleic acid rna
you set up another assay uh
for just for covid so it would require
two separate runs other than that uh uh
everything is similar you run for
rosh kobas and thermofish attack pad
only one time and you get all three
results
so
one thing i uh we we noticed that on
applied bio code one of the covet
positive results fail
or invalid because of the internal
control so in that situation
we did not have one
result
valid result
so in conclusion
it was not much uh very exciting data uh
in a way it is a good thing for uh lab
uh and uh
so so the study was completed with
hundred percent uh agreement between all
three assays
and
we we saw that they all equally perform
well
and effectively uh for our infectious
this is testing and now multiplex pcr
tests can save both
to the lab and to the patient
significant headache in this case
we see a lot of people coming to our
drive-through have respiratory
symptoms
and they are
just concerned about or stressed out
around kovid
and when we test uh definitely kovit
is in some cases is not uh
positive
but
at that time we
the order was only for kovit and we ran
only for kovitz so we
we would not know uh whether any
influenza
was detected or not
so
and lastly i would say that with more
viruses
entering into our ecosystems multiplex
testing is very trustworthy route
to differentiate between
different infections
for effectively managing the patient
and here i'd like to first thank you
thermofisher for giving us opportunity
to evaluate
and
popular healthcare r rnd team here
specific to
lee wink
one of our r d scientist uh toe gang our
supervisor for molecular infectious
disease and mia trung
who helped
carrying out this study and
happy to
hand back to lauren
great thank you so much dr patel for
sharing your data and your experiences
um i'd like to spend the last 10 minutes
just wrapping up with an introduction to
the applied biosystems takpath kovid 19
flu a flu b combo kit
for this tack path kovin 19 flu a floopy
combo kit is an all-in-one real-time
pcbr respiratory test
so this is a single test for stars kobe
2 influenza a and influenza b it
simultaneously differentiates between
the respiratory viruses and helps
identify cases of co-infection
this is an affordable and scalable
solution
increasing testing throughput in lab
efficiency it has sensitive and specific
rt-pcr detection boasting a robust
performance for detection of cobia 19
flu a and b
and the results are automated by the
pathogen interpogen software which
quickly interprets results to expedite
reporting and reduces risk of user
interpretation era
this kit is available in the us under
fda uea emergency use authorization only
and for more information about the
product details you could see more on
our product landing page but just to
mention
that kit targets the s and gene s and n
genes of stars cov2 the matrix genes of
influenza a and the matrix genes of
influenza b
we do have an ms2 internal control as
well as a positive control
and we'll go over the authorized sample
types sample prep kits and systems in
the next few slides
so this is the authorized workflow that
dr patel briefly
had an overview of anywhere from
receiving samples to sample prep to
real-time pcr to data analysis
the taxpath kova 19 flu a floopy combo
kit is a simple modular and mostly
automated workflow
the user can easily add to their
existing coven 19 testing menu in
existing infrastructure to expand their
respiratory sample testing
while maintaining a low operational cost
and workflow simplicity so we'll go
through each of these stages of the
workflow in a little more detail
starting with
receiving samples
a clinical sample clinical laboratory
receives samples collected from
nasopharyngeal swabs or interior nasal
swabs
next is an automated sample preparation
step
so in this step
the magmax viral pathogen 2 nucleic acid
isolation kit is used on the king
fixture flex purification system the 96
deep well head and deep well heat block
next there's a manual qpcr step followed
by an automated qpcr set using the
tacpaf kit
on either the 7500 fast dx real-time pcr
system or the quant studio 5 real-time
pcr system
finally data is analyzed using the
applied biosystems pathogen interpretive
software
so not only does the software
automatically interpret test results but
it also automatically performs qc for
all controls on the plate and alerts
users for the completion of data
analysis
it generates interpretive report
including each specimen and generates
lab configurable exports for laboratory
information system integration
such as the one that we heard for in dr
patel's presentation
all in all
the in the context of co-circulating
stars cov2 and influenza
running multiple tests on each patient
can be difficult time consuming and
expensive
combining targets for each virus into a
single test makes distinguishing these
infections much easier and can help
physicians choose the appropriate
treatment and protocols for their
patients
the taxpayers coven 19 flu afub combo
kit is an ideal solution for researchers
and healthcare providers with its
end-to-end workflow taking about three
hours for 94 samples
this is an effective solution and you
can learn more at thermofisher.com
forward slash coven 19flu
okay so now to get into
performance characteristics just a
little bit
so the limit of detection study
was established
to figure out the lowest viral
concentrations that can be detected by
the kid in at least 95 percent of cases
negative nasopharyngeal swabs were
pooled and spiked with the indicated
strains of virus at a range of
concentrations and processed through the
workflow
and what we saw is that for stars kobe 2
a minimum of 100 genomic copy
equivalents per milliliter were detected
and so influenza a between 200 and 500
dce per ml depending on the strains were
detected and for influenza b again
depending on the lineage between 500 and
1000 gce per ml were detected
now when we look at this limit of
detection
compared to our competitors we can see
our limit of detection here in red for
influenza a b as well as stars cov2
compared to those of some competitors so
we have the cobus and sessio gene expert
here in green
we can see that for influenza a our
limit of detection outperforms
competitors while for influenza b and
stars cov2
our limit of detection is
in the range with the competition
so our inclusivity data
in vitro analysis was performed for
influenza a
functional testing was performed to
determine the lowest concentration that
would produce positive results in all
replicates
and then it was found that in 100
of cases all 10 of these common strains
were detected for this lowest
concentration
similarly for influenza b
we can see that all five of these common
influenza b lineages
or detected 100 of the time at these low
concentrations
here's the competitive interference
study so for this study negative
nosopharyngeal swabs were pooled and
then they were spiked with combinations
of stars kobe 2 influenza a and
influenza b
in certain combinations where one virus
was
at a very low concentration one was at a
very high concentration and one was
absent so in these cases as you can see
no competitive interference was detected
and you can also see very high
sensitivity as well as high accuracy for
the virus that was
spiked in at a low concentration
and so
from this study we can tell that this
test is very accurate even in the
presence of co-infections
and finally the clinical study results
so in a clinical evaluation study was
carried out on archived nasopharyngeal
specimens these samples were tested
using the attack path covid19 flu a4b
combo kit as well as two fda approved
comparator tests both for stars code 2
and influenza
and you can see here that the positive
percent agreement and negative percent
agreement
exceed the fda agreement for performance
guidelines
okay and then the very last thing that i
want to mention is that there are
multiple multiplex testing solutions for
coping 19 and the flu
on the left we see the kit that we've
been talking about today is tacpath
cobia 19 flu afluvi combo kit
this is a single test that detects and
differentiates between the two viruses
with a high sensitivity and specificity
and then on the right we can see attack
path coven 19 fluid food b rsv combo kit
so this is
essentially the same test that with rsv
included
in this test which helps diagnose and
monitor the spread of this respiratory
virus as well
this also boasts a high sensitivity and
specificity with robust performance for
detecting starscoby2 influenza a b as
well as rsc a b
these products are highly regulated and
not approved in all countries please
visit thermofisher.com covid19 iisu for
all country specific instructions for
use
and with that that's all i have thank
you very much
thank you lauren and nanami for your
informative presentation we will now
start the q a portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
let's get started
our first question is
how accurate is a multiplex test versus
a one virus test
i'm sorry who is this question for is
that for
no
it's not it doesn't it doesn't say
either way
um okay well i can definitely chip in
first um so i would say you know in
terms of multiplex pcr um there are
certainly
some cons when using a multiplex pcr for
very very large panels um there can be
competition
for reagents there can be primer
interaction for very very large very
complex
panels that you can certainly see a loss
in sensitivity due to that but
you know for panels such as this it's it
is a multiplex but there's so few
targets
that we really don't see that drop in
sensitivity and then also you know for
commercial assays those things are
tested very robustly so um things like
competition for the master mix or um you
know things like that that's very
thoroughly investigated so for our flu a
flubi copen 19 combo kit you can see in
our clinical evaluation for example we
tested our kit with um
single virus tests and you saw the above
95
at sensitivity so
uh it still remains very accurate
um dr patel i saw you put your hands up
if you wanted to
add some information or add anything to
that
uh yeah sure
so
we after this study the data presented
here
uh we we uh look at the same
samples by uh just uh sarsko v2 essay we
ran
and we did not see any significant
difference uh positive remain positive
so we did not lose
and at the same time the crossing
threshold uh between combo and single
test
were very close uh no statistical
difference
great thank you
next question
are co-infections a real possibility
um
oh yes go for it
yeah uh as far as co-infection yeah
that's a very good question uh i think
yes it is possible uh to have flu as
well as uh other respiratory illness and
uh kuwait 19 at the same time
as as we are where we are right now
health experts are looking and and and
studying how common this can be uh we
don't know uh we don't have a lot of
data yet
but uh some of the symptoms of the
influenza and kovis
are so similar and it it it does make it
very hard to
distinguish uh based on symptoms uh only
uh whether it is uh influenza infection
or sarsko we do uh so the test uh
would be in that situation helpful uh to
differentiate between influenza and
kovid
yeah i i absolutely agree and um
just to add the fact that you know there
is very very little epidemiological
evidence of um covid or flu and covid
co-infection just because there's such
little testing of the flu since there
was hardly any flu season last year and
because the coven 19 pandemic you know
not many people are actually testing for
this but you see some studies done on
this co-infection and it's um it's a
pretty wide range of results worldwide
because it depends so much on geographic
location as well as the prevalence of
influenza at that time and at that place
so you know you'll see some people do
studies during and influence the
outbreak and of course those numbers
will be very different than someone
doing a study just on retrospective
samples um kind of more out of out of
curiosity so i've seen anywhere between
you know in certain population subgroups
you know 0.2 percent of all positive
coveted tests will also test positive
for influenza whereas in other places at
other times like for example in wuhan
china during the first outbreak of covet
i think it was up to 54 percent
co-infection with influenza
and then in parts of california right
now i know that the california
department of health um published a
paper where about 23
of positive covid cases um also tested
positive for influenza a so you know
this range of 0.2 to 50 really kind of
demonstrates
the fact that it is it is very possible
but it is so highly dependent on on
where you're testing and who you're
testing
thank you
our next question is
is the interpretive software included in
the kit
for either of you
um so for the applied biosystems
interpretive software when you purchase
the kit you purchase the kit from the
from the landing page for the combo
of the kovid flew a floofy kit
and then there is also a
customer support contact number that you
contact for your your software
um so you would just go to the
thermofisher.com website or you can also
go to thermofisher.com forward slash
contact us
and that will give you a direct link to
you know customer support and the
service center i say support and that's
where you get in touch with a
representative and they will hook you up
with the interpretive software
great thank you
next question how can i order the kit
um yep same thing so you can go to the
thermofisher.com
and enter the i believe the catalog
number is
a49868 so just search for the takpath
coven 19 for a fubi combo kit and from
that page you'll be able to request a
quote um alternatively you can you can
go to that same page the
thermofisher.com
forward slash contact us page and work
with your sales representative to order
a kit
great thank you
we're going to wrap up with this last
question this is for a nami how much
hands-on work was involved in running
the three essays
yeah so uh for running thermo fissure
tac path uh flu and covet combo assay uh
again uh if i break down by
processing the sample extracting rna on
kingfisher so hands-on time
for full plate 94 samples and two
controls about 30 minutes
and then on kingfisher it takes about 20
minutes and then another 15 minutes or
so
to set up
pcr plate and then it goes on
on studio
so um here and and then after uh pcr is
done
uh
analytical software will
uh will generate the data
excuse me
and it takes about another 10 minutes
to review and release so less than one
hour
and similar thing
on applied bio code
uh but
on rosh kobas i would say maybe 30 to 40
minutes
hands on time
all right
well thank you lauren and nanami do you
have any final comments for our audience
all right well thank you again lauren
and nanami for your time today and your
important research before we go i'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today
and for their interesting questions i'd
also like to thank our sponsors thermo
fisher scientific for sponsoring today's
webinar
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until november twenty twenty
three
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you